welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and today our
guest is Vivek Sharma an assistant
professor of political science at Yale
professor Sharma is broadly interested
in the relationship between social
institutions and political order
including alliances warfare and violence
to this end he is working on several
projects that examine property kinship
military organization and political
authority both secular and
ecclesiastical in the history of Europe
today we'll talk with Professor Sharma
about his social theory of war welcome
professor Sharma well thank you for
having me your paper develops a theory
of war based on key conceptual ideas
developed by Carl von Clausewitz that's
what about him well Klaus Yvette's is a
particularly interesting person to start
with to start any analysis of war with
because he was a soldier a highly
sensitive soldier dealing with the
defeat the catastrophic defeat of his
society I mean we often think that
defeat has the advantage of
concentrating the mind and what claws of
its did was in a sense try and
understand what it was about the French
Revolution that enabled it to defeat the
old order that he was a part of and he
did some very deep thinking about the
nature of war and its relationship to
politics and so I think everybody is
familiar with the basic cliche that that
closet which is famous for and that is
that war is a political process right or
it's the continuation of politics by
other means ok and what is your argument
in the paper well what I've tried to do
for a variety of reasons in contemporary
American political science we have
tended to to deviate from a longer
tradition a longer sociological
tradition thinking about about thinking
about war and what
trying to do is to show my colleagues in
international relations and beyond what
it is that can be gained by by starting
with the with the sociology of war and
these are basically concepts that are
about the nature of society and how that
relates to conflict and my argument is
that that there are basically two kinds
of wars there are Wars about rulership
and that there are wars about the rules
and I try and use this to explain why it
is that you get variation in the
intensity of violence why it is that
some wars are more violent more
destructive and less easy to solve than
others and I basically argue and i apply
insights from the political economy of
institutions to the study of conflict so
so in effect my work is an introduction
of clouds of its to the political
economy of institutions okay and in your
paper there are three sections where you
structure your argument tell us about
that yeah i mean the the unfortunately
clouds of it's even though his his most
famous aphorism you know war is a it's
the continuation of politics by other
means isn't well known his work is
actually not read by by contemporary
american political scientists and so the
first section is really to try and
remind people what it is that he said in
why he said it and it's important to
revisit not just the historical context
but the theoretical conclusions that he
drew from from it and so the first
section in a sense deals with the french
revolution and its impact on on europe
and how it is that Clausewitz and his
milieu because it wasn't simply clouds
of it but various people within the
prussian high command within within
within the austrian within the austrian
establishment who really had to do some
deep thinking about why it is that they
were losing why it is that they were
being catastrophic Lee defeated and what
it is that they would need to do to
respond to it so that's the first
section the second section then moves
beyond clouds of its
and and the first section is not saying
anything original about clouds of its I
mean it's it's a fairly straightforward
rendition of his work and his times the
second section is where it really wears
you know is the real contribution that
I'm making and that is to lay out in
institutional terms what it is that's
going on now Klaus if it's had the
insight that there is a difference
between limited war and total war but he
died before he could fully develop that
and nobody has really taken an up you
know where he left off and so the second
section and you know again this is what
in a sense what what I'm really
contributing to to to the study of war
is to try and lay this out in rigorous
social science terms but what this means
i mean why it is that you would get
limited and why it is that you would get
total war and that's the dimension and
that's the well that's the section in
which i developed this institutional
theory of war in effect arguing that we
cannot understand war we cannot
understand conflict without
understanding the underlying social
institutions that are being contested or
not in the case of limited war so the
basic argument there is that there that
you would get two kinds of conflicts the
first type of conflict is about rank and
status and the argument is that
conflicts about rank and status are
analogues to phenomenon that we would
find in primatology in any kind of
social hierarchy and that is that there
will always be conflict about who is at
the top of the heap and my argument is
that conflicts about that about whether
who's going to be the Pope or who is
going to be the president or who's going
to be the leader nine that actually will
be limited right it will be limited
because very little else is going to
change right it wouldn't matter in a
coup in a dictatorship whether we know
one general or the other rules or rather
that affects a very very small number of
people and therefore the violence it
tends to generate is limited on the
other side and the
the more interesting I or at least what
I think is the more interesting form of
conflict is the total war what
Clausewitz would have called total war
and what I'm calling conflicts about
about rules institutional rules and the
basic argument or the basic intuition is
that those conflicts generate higher
levels of violence they are much much
more difficult to resolve because the
numbers of people that are affected by
the by the changes is quite large so if
you if you think about what institutions
are I mean institutions are just power
relations they are their legitimate
power relations and they matter because
they structured daily life they
structure how it is that people relate
to one another and if you change them
you're likely to have great resistance I
mean to just give you an example from
the contemporary South Asia I mean
Pakistan for example has had numerous
coos in its history or the military
displaces civilian leadership and those
those types of conflicts I mean very few
people get killed in fact very often
nobody gets killed there's violence but
it's not intense and in fact in Pakistan
everybody knows when a cooze going on to
basically stay indoors you wait for a
message to come from you know whoever
controls the capital and then everybody
goes home and and and and and there's
very little that has changed what's
going on right now and Pakistan is
actually much more dangerous and much
more much more more worrisome because
it's not simply about who is going to be
the president of Pakistan or who's going
to be the chief of staff of the army
what is going on are various groups that
are contesting the basic constitutional
structure of the state and that actually
alienates much greater numbers of people
it alienates power segments that will
resist that under normal circumstances
under the circumstances of a coup they
wouldn't resist so that's the second
section and then the third section is
simply applying
this 22 to a range of social science
literature's as well as two debates like
the clash of civilizations and so the
argument there is that is that the
social science literature is on conflict
have fundamentally missed some basic
basic conceptual distinctions that need
to be made in order to explain the sorts
of things that we would like to explain
in effect I'm saying that what we
require is a much deeper understanding
of the sociology of conflict in order to
have the kinds of theories that we would
like to have so that would be the third
section okay and what is your
implication for your social theory of
war well the hubris of the project is
that is that I can explain a great deal
more than than than others but I'll give
you a few a few examples the first
example would be that there's a tendency
both in the public domain but also in
the social science literature is on
conflict to either talk about about
conflict from the perspective of states
or from the perspective of individual
leaders that are making decisions and
there is been there has been very little
attempt to unify these different levels
of analysis and the basic argument that
I'm making is that it is in fact
possible to deal with at least two
levels of analysis at the individual
level as well as the societal level in a
unified theory and so the first
implication is that there's much greater
explanatory power but if you want to
think about this in terms of current
debates from the perspective of people
who are concerned about religious
conflict there's a tendency to to to
deal with religious conflict from the
perspective of what motivates individual
actors and there's utility in that right
so so the way the question tends to get
framed in in the public domain is well
what is it about these five lines in the
Quran or in the Bible that would lead
somebody to go blow themselves up and on
on the streets and what I'm saying is
that well that may not necessarily be
the most truthful way to go about
looking at the problem that what what is
much more important for understanding
patterns of violence is what it is that
are the stakes of the conflict what it
is that the actors are actually doing as
opposed to why they do it and so it's
not that what it's not that intentions
and motivations are irrelevant it's just
that they're not going we're not going
to be able to answer the sorts of
questions that we would we would like to
based on simply looking at people's
motivations and so to give you an
example I mean what what is deeply
problematic about about about the the
rise of Islamic sonic militants in
Pakistan is not so much that they are
Islamic it's that they are threatening
particular categories of institutions
and that in itself would explain why it
is that you get the intensities of
violence and why it is that you get
resistance and then there are other
other implications i mean the the one
that would probably make most sense to
two people out in the public domain
relates to this whole clash of
civilizations thesis that that Samuel
Huntington had put forth in the 1990s
and Samuel Huntington got a lot of flack
for for arguing that that culture in
effect I mean he didn't quite use those
terms but in effect culture matters for
understanding conflict and he got a lot
of flack for it because it violated our
liberal sensibilities about about how
the world works and what I'm saying is
that that that I mean Huntington's
analysis was wrong I mean there is no
clash of civilizations but I think that
his basic intuition that we need to
understand social organization which
includes culture in any analysis of
conflict is right and I think it's been
very unfortunate that people haven't
taken Huntington up on hit on on on his
agenda
for political reasons and that's so that
would be that would that would be the
other major okay you raised two major
issues in your conclusion a common
reference point for the study of war and
a macro level approach to conflict why
are these important okay well I'll the
the the the macro level that has to do
with sort of internal debates within
political science and so the general
trends over the last 10 to 15 years has
been to move to the micro level and that
is to look at individual level factors
in explaining conflict and I'm saying
that well I mean while there is a great
deal of utility in that what we need to
do is to spend much more time thinking
about groups because war is not simply
about two individuals in conflict war is
about groups and we cannot we cannot
hope to understand war as distinctive
from from fighting between two
individuals unless we take the sociology
of group behavior seriously and I and
and I that's the agenda that I'm pushing
within within the social sciences and in
terms of in terms of a common framework
again this is a this relates to to how
it is that the social sciences have been
have been dealing with conflict there
are a number of distinct research
communities within within the social
sciences within anthropology with in
history within political science and to
a lesser extent with in sociology and
these are all distinctive communities
distinctive research communities that
are not talking to one another and I
think that we are in effect constantly
reinventing the wheel and each of these
sub in T sub research communities
without actually making progress and of
course as a political scientist I really
do believe that we in political science
have a great deal to learn from
historians from anthropologist and from
sociologists and so I'm trying to
demonstrate to to my colleagues what why
it is that they
read history why it is that they should
read anthropology why they should be
aware of Faber and marks and Durkheim
from from sociology so if everyone in
those different disciplines worked to
get together we might come up with more
solutions to the problems we face I
certainly think we'll do a better job
than we're doing now yeah okay well
thank you very much for being with us
here today and sharing some of your
research well thank you for having me
for more information about professor
Sharma and his work please visit our
website at yale edu backslash Macmillan
report for sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you